all right
let's
do it
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back
to yo absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
riven with griffin
you know
nba playoffs still going on and i'm so
excited about it
it's one of the best playoffs i've seen
in a while even though some of the
biggest stars aren't in it but who cares
a lot of stuff to talk about there so if
you're in the nba stick around
uh i love this show moon night we're
going to talk about that
and just a bunch of little things going
on in the world my wedding is coming up
talking about that talking about some
weird stuff rachel i do and
but anyways
welcome back
[Music]
all right
riverwood griffin is back in the house
thanks for being here
no ads today
but i will say if you
feel so inclined you want to support the
show even more there's a lot of ways to
do it you could uh become a patreon
member
i got some backlog videos i got to put
up there
so you could do that
join me on patreon or
uh twitch you can become a twitch also
subscriber and you can join me there or
you know just watch me every day i
stream on twitch
but
for most part thank you for subscribing
and being a part of the show why is that
subscribe so little man that's
what
i don't even make sense man
this should not be that little let me
wait let me fix this right now all right
there we go
i don't know if it worked but let's see
let's do it again
there we go
man it's like it's like i got to do
everything my damn self when you're like
alone doing it
all right so anyway subscribe share all
that kind of great stuff so i appreciate
you guys
doing that
um and if you you know like i say if
you're so inclined all the links and
stuff for there so thanks for uh
thanks for supporting the show
um what's up guys uh
okay a lot of stuff going on
i guess
um
yeah you know i'm getting married it's
getting closer less than it's like 50
days or something like that i don't know
i would say that i was nervous at first
or like you know you're not sure i mean
like again it's like i just
i don't know what i'm doing doing it
this late in life
so let me just say this if you're a
young man
you know your late 20s early 30s if you
are thinking about one
being a father okay so this is important
to think about if you think about being
a father then i suggest that you really
if you're in a relationship consider is
this the person that you want to do this
with can you build a life with this
person because you know you got to think
about kids man like how old are you
going to be when they you know when they
get older as you get older i'm 50 so
we're gonna have to start now i'm gonna
i'm gonna be trying to play catch and my
back's gonna be hurting i'm gonna be
like you need to move closer you know
what i mean like
so i mean
i
i don't know i mean i don't regret my
life at all but if i had thought about
if someone had talked to me like this
maybe i would have made a different
choice maybe someone older had said to
me hey
is this really something you want to
think about i mean because we're so
selfish we're always thinking about
ourselves we're always thinking about
our own life and like
how what's going on with us me me me me
me and you know when you get other
people in your life it becomes not just
about you it becomes a team it becomes
like them and what you want to do for
your family and it's like so you know i
understand maybe you're thinking like oh
i don't want to do this so you're scared
but just think like you know when your
kid is 10 how old do you want to be when
your kid is 20 how old do you want to be
you get what i'm saying and so like
i feel like i've lived a whole lifetime
and now i'm starting a whole new life
right now and so i don't even get to
rest so i feel like i did it in reverse
so whatever the rest i did or whatever
the selfishness of just looking out for
me and doing stuff for me now those days
are gone so now my older age i'm gonna
be like taking care of people it's it's
uh you know
that's daunting you know what i mean i'm
ready for the challenge i'm excited
about it i wouldn't want to do it with
any other person
love rachel she's uh you know
rachel said something so funny to me
i don't know she gonna hate me for even
talking about this
well rachel has this thing you know she
was so she's on her period right and
she's like do you know how to put in a
tampon and i'm like no like no i do not
and that's not something that i want in
my mental rolodex right and then she's
you know and did she get stubborn about
it she said well you need to know how to
do that you know what she goes what if
we have a daughter and you die and she
goes she dies she goes what if i die and
you have a daughter what are you gonna
tell her i'm like well
this i don't know if any little girl
wants their father telling them how to
put in a tampon so that was my first
like pushback i was like what are you
talking about but she was adamant about
it she was like no you need to know how
to do this
i think it was just her thing i think
she just wanted me to do it so there's
like this whole thing about i want you
to do it and then she goes her
her reasoning is well what if i lose my
arms
if i lose my arms you're gonna have to
do this for me and i was like
okay
and i just thought it was super adorable
that she thought i would stay with her
if she lost her arms
you know what i mean
like [ __ ] i'm out you don't got no arms
i'm just kidding
obviously i'm just kidding all right i'm
just being facetious and that's gonna be
a funny joke on stage
but
so
it was this whole thing and then you
know
we did it
oh and rachel also did something
hilarious
so i was in houston over the weekend and
shout out to people in houston it was
actually a great weekend people of
houston were fantastic i had such a good
time i actually have some clips i had
some like crowd work clips on this drive
that i have right here so i need to like
put those up on the internet
crowd work stuff is always good you're
not burning material
but so
i get a text from rachel and she's like
mortified because
she
she was sending me some like topless
pictures you know
being cute and sexy but she accidentally
sent them to her mom
[Laughter]
i mean
so then she screenshots the text with
her and her mom and he's like
you know topless pictures she's like so
rachel's like oh my god i'm so sorry i
meant to send that to eric and then like
rachel's mom
her mom's all like
it's okay well he'll like these you know
oh man so oh that's just so that that is
just is that like the worst thing ever
like what do you guys think is that the
worst thing ever should we put up a poll
you know
uh like what's the worst thing ever that
you've ever done you know we'll put that
in the chat and then and you could say
it in the chat you could put it up in
the comments
like
have you ever sent
a nude pic
to someone that you should not be
sending a nude pic to
by accident you know and it's funny
because we're in this like group chat
like with her family so there's like 20
people members of her family in this
group chat and i was just thinking what
if she would have sent it there that
would have been a nightmare
that would be a nightmare oh wow
so
so fun times with uh
with with rachel oh so i see people in
the chat like i saw my mom's nudes once
you know what's crazy is think about
this
the way technology is now
like there's
no way
you're going to have to delete all this
stuff or hide it kids are like little
detectives they're going to be all in
your stuff i mean there's so many
pictures and inappropriate pictures and
like even just provocative pictures that
you might have
on your phone in your cloud that just
you know thousands and thousands and
thousands of pictures man
you know so like what are you gonna do
like you know like
i mean people are gonna see this your
kids are gonna see this they're gonna be
like what's going on i mean i think the
internet's crazy because of like
it's like
on instagram
hoes actually become housewives
you know what i mean like i don't know
how we've been on the tenure i don't
know how many times i've seen
like a person that like
maybe i talked to 10 years ago
you know who was like being like
whatever and then now they got kids and
a husband i'm like [ __ ] you
you was different ten years ago
so
there's gonna be a lot of that man
you know i don't know i don't know how
how do people raise kids in this
generation like who you know who's got a
10 11 12 14 year old right now with the
way the internet is
but but even you know but even now if
you think about like the people like if
you were 20 10 years ago and you were
being you know nasty on the internet and
now you're 40
you know you know whatever it is you
know what i mean
if you're 30s in your 30s now or
i just think that
in the next 10 years that generation
where it was like so fluid of people
just passing around pictures and doing
stuff
then these people are now going to have
kids 10 12 13 14 years old and then
they're gonna be the ones gonna be like
looking through stuff and being like oh
my god mom why do you have 40 pictures
of yourself in a bikini on the internet
you know what i mean so it's going to be
that kind of stuff
so i see somebody in the chat linda
lopez i told my husband he's not allowed
to send me inappropriate messages to me
anymore because he's always responding
to my direct messages in our group chat
with my parents so i can't take the
chance i mean i get that
you know what i mean i get that but it's
like you know
the good thing about it's still fun to
be like sexy and flirty that's the good
thing about texting and the messaging i
like being flirty with rachel she'll
like send me pictures i'll send her
pictures you know she's like send me a
video or whatever especially when i'm on
the road that kind of stuff so you know
it's fun uh
but it's like when you got kids you got
to start thinking about like you make
sure you have a you know your phone
locked but then there's the whole thing
about like do you want your phone locked
you know yeah but i think you should
have your phone locked no matter what
just just for the simple fact that you
can lose it and like i have all my
credit cards and my apple pay i have all
that stuff like nah man this is about
trust issue whatever my phones my phones
stay locked because you know you never
know
i got so many people's numbers and stuff
in here you don't want that situation
you don't want to be like on your phone
and then all of a sudden
you know what i mean you lose your phone
and then all of a sudden somebody's
buying a tv
with your apple pay because it's nothing
you know so
i don't know
all right anyways uh big news um
[Music]
big news uh to today or yesterday the
mask mandate has been lifted y'all
the mask mandate for travelers no longer
in effect
and how do i feel about it
i am a hooray hurrah guy for this
because i travel probably more than most
of you
i mean
here's what i feel about it
the way we're at right now
you either vaccinated or you're not
okay
if you're not
and you have the risk of getting it then
you might end up in the hospital
and whatever worst case scenario
situation all right
i got it
i felt terrible for a couple of days
and i also felt like
my vaccine was working
i really felt like that and believe me
i'm not just saying i'm forget the
politics of it okay i'm just telling you
i felt like
oh this could have been worse for me you
know
uh without it right so do you whatever
you want to do i'm not trying to tell
you do whatever you want but at this
point though in society i feel like we
got to be about looking out for ourself
take care of yourself
first make sure you look out for you so
whatever you're doing to take care of
yourself do that uh enough of like
making everybody else do what everybody
else wants so
if you're a person
that likes
that thinks it's you want to be extra
safe wear your mask on the plane
and mind your damn business
that's where we need to get back to and
i understand totally why the airlines
don't want to do this because you got
people who are just trying to do their
job as a
[Music]
flight attendant and now you also got to
be police with people who you don't know
how these people are going to react so i
think it put people in a tense situation
you know hey excuse me you need to do
this and you know you saw all the videos
there's so many videos online of people
going crazy right
so now it's going to be like but i still
think it's gonna happen because it's
gonna be like maybe you sit next to
somebody who's like
they wanna wear a mask i'm not gonna be
wearing a mask on a plane i'm just not
if i get a sense i'm sitting next to
somebody that like got the sniffles or
something maybe i will i'ma have my mask
with me just in case you know you never
know maybe i'm not feeling under the
weather whatever it is like that but if
i don't want to i won't be
my joe business
like if you want to do it do it and
that's how it should be anyway i mean
how many times before all this i would
see asian people at the airport
wearing masks and i'd be like what's
wrong with that that looks crazy i don't
think like that anymore now i get it
yeah so if that so
that's how i feel about it i think we're
over this i think we're done with it how
it's affecting our lives i think there's
still an imminent threat i think that uh
there's still
things to worry about
but i thought i don't think we handled
it properly so now we're gonna handle it
the way we're handling it now and it's
up to you
so
you know because it's just sad to hear
all these stories of people who are
in the hospital about to die
talking about
can i get the vaccine and they're like
i'm sorry
so that's a lot of stories about that
okay
and then of course you have the people
that push back who will be like well you
can become impotent you could you know
become whatever the stuff whatever you
think is wrong with the thing
either way
all i'm saying is how we handling it now
is how i want to handle it i'm walking
into a restaurant with my mask off i'm
traveling i'm walking around the airport
with my mask off
i can understand if you want to be on
the plane yes i get that you know i
haven't even decided but in terms of
like when i'm just like in a space
forget that because it just
i hated it we all hated it
so boom thank goodness it's done
according to um
you know so some judge in some place
you know said this is
far beyond the cdc's uh you know purview
to
have this mandate
the administration already said yeah
we're we're dropping the mandate and so
here we are so let's live our lives you
know what i mean let's live our lives
canada
they still got their nonsense going on
like fine
you know it's like people just won't be
visiting canada you know
like you know you have to be fully
vaccinated to travel to canada i don't
know if you still need to cover test and
all that nonsense to travel to canada i
hope not because that was just a racket
i've said it before and i'll say it
again it was a racket
so hopefully
they got rid of all that
and we could just now start you need to
take care of your personal health you
know you need to take care of your
personal health you know i'm exercising
you know at least four times a week now
i'm trying to get myself in better shape
and i'm trying to like you know so we
can fight off these kinds of things take
your vitamins uh you get your fish oil
whatever you got to do make sure you're
taking care of yourself so you can fight
off whatever is coming your way
all right
anyways
all right guys
um let's get into
uh
one of my favorite topics right now
and it is the n
b
a
playoffs
okay
i want to get into these nba playoffs
wait what's going on why is my
why is it so little like that oh i'm so
sorry
what i did this is crazy i wanted to do
that there we go
there we go
there it is
boom
i don't know what happened there
new version of my software came out
okay so there we go
oh let me uh put a stream marker so when
i'm doing the things all right so nba
playoffs guys let's get into it
playoff time uh the the games
have been absolutely fantastic
uh
right
um
let's just go one time so
let's get into the the one series that
is like um to to me
it doesn't even make sense that this is
a first round series but it is what it
is you know what i mean and of course
that's the nets and the celtics the
number two seed versus the nets who are
the number seven seed who probably if
everything was working out proper great
would be um a number one or two seed at
least minimum three
at the minimum three but we getting this
really great first round series that's
got like a sort of eastern finals uh
atmosphere to it
you know uh the the celtics won on a
buzzer beater
uh really great team play
i don't know i like the celtics to win
the series still
i do um i just i feel like
i don't know i don't think the the nets
have enough
i don't think they run their offense uh
in a way efficiently a way to win a
playoff series but who knows they can
still win the championship for all we
know because those two guys are that
good but there's enough stats to show
that like when they both score 60 i'm
saying when they combine for 60 they
don't have a great record
uh you know they need other people on
that team
to step up so kyrie irving went for 39
points five rebounds and six assists i
mean the dude was bawling game one right
you know you just saw what a fantastic
talent and then the crowd was getting on
them they were like boo calling them
names and he was flicking them off he
got five fifty thousand dollars for that
i mean i don't how do i feel about i
mean you know
i'm a i've been a fan in the crowd and
i've yelled things at the at the the
players i've never been like
inappropriate in terms like that but we
get into it i remember one time i was at
the game with adam devine and we're
sitting there and russell westbrook was
he was uh he was playing for oklahoma
city at the time i believe still or it
could have been houston whoever he was
playing for we adam and i were yelling
at him we had really good seats like
third row you know what i mean and we
were like boo russell
you suck are we saying all this
and he turned and looked at us
excuse me and he gave us a death stare
that
both him and i
like
like we went we visibly went ooh you
know like we still we looked at each
other like oh he's gonna you know we
really were like like fearful he was he
he has like this look and then like one
of the guys that talks to us all the
time one of the clippers people comes
over and goes hey what'd you guys say to
westbrook
you know what i mean so i get it fans
interact and he's and i
i actually don't have a problem with
this i mean it's iffy because you know
sports are like it's a family show
per se and so you have like kids
watching so that's always the thing
people go kids kids kids kids and i get
that i don't have kids yet but i want to
have kids and so i'm already thinking
like that so it is a family show so it's
like you know we don't want players
cursing and and acting up you know it is
what it is though you know what i mean
he got fined so you move on with your
life but i feel like the boston people
are gonna really give it to him they're
gonna they're gonna
you know what i mean like they're going
to um
they're gonna make it worse for him so
let's see how he responds but i thought
boston was better they won the
rebounding matchup they had more
rebounds you know they they had more
assists i just think that boston is a
better team i think jason tatum is an
underrated superstar i feel like jason
tatum should really be in the mvp
conversation for what he's done he's
only 24 years old and he's always there
they've been to the eastern conference
final already twice already they just
ran into lebron james you know if you
think about it lebron james has been to
the championship
he went to the championship 10 times
so
this is what happened with jordan
jordan stopped great teams from
achieving their goal
and so we don't remember those teams but
there was a cavs teams with dorty and
mark price
that cavs team was excellent they
couldn't beat michael jordan there was a
nick the knicks team with the with the
you know ewing and all them guys they
had so many chances they couldn't get
past michael jordan you have the
stockton malone didn't get a
championship charles barkley didn't get
a championship i mean you know you know
what i'm saying there were so many
teams in the east that couldn't get past
jordan so we don't remember those teams
that's the same thing that happened with
lebron james i think boston could have
already had a championship if it wasn't
for lebron james
lebron james
he stopped
that pistons team
the pistons would with that eventually
won a championship by the way they won a
championship when they played the lakers
uh but that team could have won more
championships but lebron james stopped
him remember the lebron james had 25 in
the fourth quarter versus detroit
and went to the championship and got
swept by san antonio but i think that
detroit team would have been a better
matchup against san antonio and possibly
could have won a championship but it
didn't get past lebron james the celtics
with
with their big three they only won one
championship and couldn't get past
lebron james so
jason tatum
same thing he was in that situation
where
they had to face lebron james and
couldn't do it so this is his time to
really prove that he is a mega star if
he could beat brooklyn and then they'll
have to face um in this next round
they'll have to face like giannis or i'm
sure the bucks are going to win that
series had to face giannis and then if
they beat them then they got to go face
the winner of
you know
philly or um um um miami you know so
it's like
this to whoever wins the east is
bonafide that's a that's a tough
conference this year so
shout out kudos to boston kevin durant
he didn't have a very good game it is
what it is this one this is what i say
about kevin durant i think he's a
phenomenal talent i'm not gonna talk i'm
not talking a lot of smack about kevin
durant he's phenomenal talent probably
the best in the game but there's too
often in big moments he shows up nine
for 25. it's just there's so many
examples of it so
if he don't play more consistently in
this series because all they got to do
another team got to do is shut down one
of them let the other one go off this
dude had 39 points five rebounds six
assists he shot over fifty percent
okay kyrie you go for yours we'll just
shut down the other one
and and then i don't think the other
guys on the nets are enough to uh
i don't think there are enough to win
that game okay
that's what i have to say about that
um
all right so then you got all right so
now let's just go through the match-ups
again now so now you got the 76ers and
the raptors all right so oh and there's
so many good great stories in the
eastern conference playoffs right now
actually in the whole nba that you'd
want to see all right i want to talk
about that real quick before i before i
move on all right let me go back to the
chat so you guys can so i can see chat
stuff what you guys are saying um
there's so many great stories okay so
what do you want to see
all right so boston has a great story
they've been to the eastern finals twice
it's time for them to show they are
superstars they got rid of their coach
they got this new coach who should be
coach of the year and they and now if
they win the championship it it
justifies everything and they're right
there right that's a that'd be a great
story not the best story but that's a
great story now you got the nets having
to deal with you know kyrie irving and
his vaccine stuff and trading
uh james harden and that drama and then
you have ben simmons who may or may not
play if the net can overcome all that
and get to the championship what a great
story but even within that story what do
we want to see
there's i would like to see the nets
play the sixers
because then
is james harden going to show up
is it going to be like that the playoff
atmosphere and be talking to smack
that's a great story love to see net
sixers
all right how about nets milwaukee
that's a great story because milwaukee
won last year but we all know
the nets were up 40
they were up 40 in game one or two like
it looked like the nets were gonna
roll over them milwaukee goes on to win
the championship right
this is milwaukee's time to go hey y'all
two are playing good kyrie's not hurt
all right we need to go beat y'all so
you can know it wasn't a fluke last year
we beat your ass last year we'll beat
you again great story
love to see
giannis ander takupo prove that he is an
all-time superstar and it wasn't a fluke
championship because of injuries and all
that stuff that's a great story right
so many great stories
here's another great story
the golden state warriors are bawling
right now okay they are bought i hate
the golden state warriors but my
clippers are out of it lakers are out of
it so if i had to support anybody in the
west it would you know all right golden
state looks good but i'm rooting for
phoenix because i like chris paul but
the golden state has a great story so
here's their story
the first championship they won it was
nonsense
kevin love and kyrie irving were hurt
and lebron took him to six games and
then beat him the next year
73 win team so we always have that in
our minds we always have that in our
minds that you shouldn't have won that
first championship
that is what it is
so they have three champions then they
got kd and won two more
so this
unit the the unit that won 73 games
the main unit of klay thompson uh what's
his name uh
green
and uh um
curry
that's that lineup they're the core of
this championship team right if they can
go on and win the championship without
kd it does two things it legitimizes
them all the championships it
legitimizes them fully even though
they're already legit okay but
really puts a stamp on it two it takes
away from kd
like this whole thing that kd was the
best and all this like nah man they did
it with you and they did it without you
twice and how great of it would be for
the nets to play
the
warriors
oh my god
nets and warriors would be a great
championship what a great story right
phoenix they got a great story if
phoenix goes to the championship again
and they win it this time it it it does
so much for chris paul's legacy it does
so much for phoenix of like showing that
they it wasn't a fluke for them either
that
what they because they had the best
record in the league they proved
themselves to be the best team in the
league so let's see if they can uh you
know fulfill that so anyways guys great
stories in the nba super excited about
that can't wait to see that go through
so all right so philly toronto let's get
back to that philly toronto i think
philly's gonna sweep them if not it'll
go five games they just don't have
enough with um
maxie tyrese maxi he's averaging 30
points a game six rebounds five assists
he's the x factor he's proven that it's
not a fluke he had a great first game he
had a great second game and what it's
doing is it's letting james harden be a
facilitator
james harden has lost a step he's not
the same guy from houston but he's
getting over 10 um assists a game he's
getting steals and all we need now all
we need from him is like 19 20 points
over 10 assists and if he gets 10
rebounds
we're solid his
game his head heady plays are doing it
so you got that right and then you if
you're gonna have maxi play like that
and then all you need is the other guy
what's his name um um um um
oh man what is the guy's name you guys
know i'm terrible with names uh the
other forward he was with the clippers
um
help me out guys
uh whatever his name you guys know who
i'm talking about that guy if he plays
well then you have four solid players
that you can get
a great game from one and and a solid
game from the others or a great game
from two it's just enough to um it's
it's enough
to keep us going you know tobias harris
thank you tobias harris so if tobias
harris gives you 20 you got mb going 25
30 with 15 rebounds 19 from hardin 25 30
from maxie whoo dangerous team i would
not be surprised if they won the
championship all right
um mavericks jazz this is a nonsense
this is a nonsense series
you know i just i don't know if luca is
gonna play in this series i hope he does
the series is tied 1-1
utah just
like neither one of these teams have a
chance to win the championship so it's
like who cares you know they just utah
just they don't got it they're missing
something go bear when he's on the court
and they go small on the other team he
just he can't guard anything he's a
great rim protector but they play better
when he's off the court
he's one of their best players so it's
hard to say and you got donovan mitchell
he's averaging 33 points in the series
and then jalen brunson for dallas is
averaging 32 for this series so if they
if they actually get luca back
man i mean dallas looked like a really a
contender but a guy that's got that sort
of injuries even if he comes back like
do you want to risk it i mean kd is a
cautionary tale like that guy's the
franchise he
when he's playing he he was responsible
for like 60 of their offense
scoring and passing so it's like do you
want to let's this season's a wash let's
i would just rest him and be like all
right we're going to come back strong
next year and let these guys earn their
stripes in the playoffs but that uh
dallas utah series has nothing to be
desired so
whatever with that man warriors nuggets
i think the warriors are going to sweep
them i mean the nuggets were fighting on
the bench
they got they got steph curry coming off
the bench you know what i mean this dude
jordan poole is averaging 29 points
three rebounds five assists
shooting lights out i just
i think that the golden state warriors
are showing themselves to be like hey we
have a championship pedigree and look
out for us so watch out for uh the
golden state warriors but this series is
over okay i'm sorry denver fans but and
then like
uh jokic
he freaking he got kicked out on purpose
yesterday he did he got kicked out on
purpose he was like i won't play this
game anymore i got no help my teammates
are fighting they're not playing defense
they're not hitting shots when i pass
them and i think he got that second tech
and was like i'm out of here i'm going
to the showers that series garbanzo
beans too uh golden state warriors are
in firm command of that series
all right heat and atlanta now the heat
are the most underrated number one seed
it's crazy because with all the other
stories in the eastern conference the
heat have managed to have the best
record and we're not talking about them
jimmy butler is leading this team he's
only averaging 21.6 rebounds four
assists i think that's pretty great you
know you know that he could do that and
then and then lead them in the way he's
leading them you know you know they got
a pretty good team
um you know
you you hope that
you know what i mean like you hoped that
they could
take care of this team early because
atlanta seems to be slipping i don't
think they they don't seem to have
enough and clint capela is not gonna be
playing in the next game i think that's
how you say his first name but capela i
think he's injured so i don't think he's
gonna play game two and then you know
they held trey young they held he's
their guy if he don't go off atlanta
loses and that's exactly what happened i
just don't see atlanta beating miami
maybe they'll get a game or two maybe
maybe two most likely they'll get one
but i see
miami taking this series and uh getting
to the next round
so
that is what it is and then you got uh
grizzlies wolves man grizzlies wolves is
the one i think the most intriguing
series in the west i think uh
minnesota the timberwolves they're
actually better than their record shows
uh they actually got a really great team
you know carl anthony uh 29 points they
got that rookie guy
i mean he's balling i mean i i don't
know i mean
this would be an upset it would be an
upset if um
if
the minnesota won because the grizzlies
were had the second seed i mean they
they were balling all year but you know
i just i don't know if
i don't know if either one of these
teams has enough to like go further but
we got to see tonight if the grizzlies
if if it was just a fluke or if they can
bounce back from this
with their lack of playoff experience
and come back but minnesota man they i'm
telling you they really look good
so
i think they got size they got defense
they got depth uh d'angelo russell's
balling um that that dude is his name
edwards what's that kid's name
you guys know me you guys are always
getting on me about uh
how i never remember anybody's name you
know i'm old relaxed
you know what i mean edward it is
edwards edwards had 36 points in his
debut yeah so that guy's balling you got
uh karl anthony towns doing what he does
on the inside and he can shoot threes he
won the three-point contest
so i don't know this is a really
intriguing series so i'd love to see who
cause then the winner of this
because they're just because this is the
yeah the second seat so two plays three
so that would be like the winner of this
got to play golden state
so that's you know you know what i mean
like
that's what i'm saying the western
conference is like it's it's not as
stacked as the other one in these
stories but i don't know i i i don't
know who's gonna win that one
um
i gotta see how the grizzlies played
tonight but if if if minnesota steals
another one that's it game over
and then obviously sons pelicans i think
the sun's i mean the pelicans are
putting up a valiant fight which if zion
was playing it'd probably be different
well they probably have a different seed
but i think the suns are gonna
roll through them and get to the next
round
chris paul is just playing lights out
and he's on a mission at 37 years old
devin booker's doing the damn thing so
we'll see how that goes and then bucks
bulls i think the bucks are going to win
that series i don't think they have
enough giannis is a monster i mean he's
also he's one of the candidates for
league mvp he's he's a he's a finalist
so i just don't see
i don't think the bulls have enough yet
to get past the bucks
so
all right
um there you go that's my uh big time
thank you charles
for the one dollar super chat
um
but yeah so that's that's how i feel
about it and in fact anybody else has
any thoughts please uh you can put your
thoughts
what you think about what i'm saying
you know you don't gotta attack me
please like sometimes people put these
comments but just like
just just have a conversation
say hey i disagree i think this this and
this but you don't gotta attack me
personally you don't know me like that
you know what i mean and if you ain't
gonna come up to my face and talk this
[ __ ] that you talk shut up on the
internet just you know be respectful
we're just trying to have some dialogue
that's what the community is about man
riffing with griffin is trying to make
it's a community of people that we just
like having conversations you know i
talk about all different kinds of stuff
you don't gotta be a dick all right guys
um now i want to talk about that's my
mba recap so let's um
let's go into this uh i wasn't gonna do
that i was like i was gonna do this on
on my patreon but i thought you know
what this is actually a really great
show so
i said let me talk about this show moon
night
have you guys seen moon night on uh
disney plus
it's actually a really great show like
i'm not
uh i'm i'm i'm a marvel i like marvel
comics but i i was getting like the you
know the big ones you know i i collected
the avengers i collected marvel team up
i got some x-men and then maybe i got
like those like you know those b ones
like alpha flight and those kinds of
ones i had but then i stopped collecting
comics but i've never even heard of some
of these characters like i've never
heard of moon knight before i didn't
know moon knight was a marvel character
feel like they're looking in their
archive of what they own from marvel and
they're just like all right let's make
this but
this is actually a really fantastic
series
uh it stars oscar isaac and he is just a
really phenomenal actor y'all um
let's go let's go to this
you know there he is right there oscar
isaac and then it stars ethan hawke
and may callum maui or i don't know kind
of terrible with names but the black
girl may
she's good i like her
uh so anyway the shows about stephen
grant discovered he's been granted the
powers of egyptian moon god but he soon
finds out that this newfound powers can
be both a blessing and a curse in his
troubled life
so um
the guy
isaac what's his name you know he's
playing two different characters and
he's doing a really great job at it so
he's playing like
this uh assassin
character american assassin guy who's
like in league with this egyptian god
who like doles out punishment after
somebody does some bad things and then
the other character is this other guy
steven who's pl he's and he's this sort
of like british nerd who works at a
museum and he's you know he's just
really introverted and weird and he's
doing a great
job playing both characters and they're
sort of fighting each other inside of
his head you know so one wants to
control the body and then the other
wants to control the body and they're
fighting against the bad guys played by
ethan hawk who is like
in league with another egyptian god
who is about this egyptian god is about
uh doling out punishment before the
punishment happens
so it's like not giving people a chance
and so that's the fight between good and
evil ethan hawks doing a great job and
oscar isaac's doing a great job this
i've only watched the first three i've
watched the first three episodes i think
tomorrow and it's only six episodes and
what i like about it is what marvel is
doing uh i love what marvel's doing man
the this like i wish like because like
here's the thing
like here's something to talk about in
the chat and in the comments
what marvel movie would you have
preferred it to be
a six
six episode
series like moonlight like moon night
like they could have easily made this a
movie
uh because it's like but i prefer six
hours of television
than
two hours of a movie and cutting out all
the stuff that they had to cut out to
put it on screen
i think this is a better way to develop
characters to follow the story to like
be involved and then like keep it going
is there going to be another season or
is now is now you've established moon
night is he going to be with the
eternals and the rest of the avengers
and
you know whoever's left and whatever the
story lines with doctor strange you know
it makes us think like that so
i wish uh
yeah somebody said the eternals you know
what i actually agree with you like
there's some things i didn't like about
the eternals i didn't like this woke
casting that they did because it's
distracting and it doesn't make any
sense why would why would the god figure
why would irish orisham the the god in
the movie in internals why would he
create these superheroes like this
like why would they be okay i'ma send a
middle-aged latina a middle-aged white
woman a asian girl with a british accent
chubby asian guy arab dude deaf girl
little tomboy and a white guy is the
most powerful and he's also the villain
oh and the chubby gay black guy that
wears glasses
really
like
like
such nonsense in terms of like
it just that is so indicative of the
times that there's no artistic integrity
in that
all they had to do
is make it where
the eternals
could morph
into whatever they wanted to
and change over time
and if this had if this is what they
ended up as
i'm on board
boom but you don't start like that
there's no freaking way you start like
that
you don't start with selma hayek having
a latino accent
in a mod in ancient egypt you know what
i'm saying
it's like sorry
you lost me you lost me with the
wokeness okay i couldn't suspend my
disbelief and i think that's more
important than anything else you have to
make the viewer
suspend their disbelief so they can
believe that what's happening on screen
could actually happen
that's movie magic
they didn't achieve that but that being
said
it's actually not a terrible movie
you know when i got past that because
i've actually watched it i've watched it
like five times
on uh disney plus i actually when i put
it on i go oh this is actually enjoyable
so i like the special effects and i like
to interact i love the stories the
interaction amongst the characters it
was great you know what they were great
actors actually pretty they were great
actors and i think they did a fabulous
job that being said
uh
but
yeah the eternals would have been a
great uh
six episode series to really get into it
you know what i mean
uh but moon knight getting back to moon
night um it's great
you know i just i just think that like
what they're doing with the whole marvel
universe is great you know i loved loki
i loved loki was a great series i loved
hawkeye that was a great series when
especially when they added the chick
from um um black widow because that girl
is great the girl that stars in black
widow
that chick's dope okay great actress i
believe her everything she says i
believe her so
hopefully she they got her in this
universe still and we'll see what
happens with that um but moon knight's
pretty good man
i'm not mad at it at all so i do highly
recommend moon knight i'm giving that
some woo-woos
[Music]
so moon knight is a a very good show so
i highly recommend that
uh yeah somebody in the chat said
eternal characters needed more backstory
completely 100 agree
give me some backstory but but if you
saw the movie
it's impossible to give them backstory
spoiler alert they're robots okay so the
backstory is and they've been doing this
for a million years
so my thing is like why are they like
this
you know what i'm saying so the other
planets they look this is what i'm
saying man like
they should have
had it where
they can change so like if the eternals
are in
you know in africa
then naked they're then they're all
black because they're they're trying to
be that you know they're trying to
blend in with society and then so if
we're talking about now it's two seven
thousand years later and they've all
decided hey i'm going to be
i'm going to be this i'm going to be
that then i'm with it but to suggest
that they started like this and they
were sent to earth and and they've been
this way for 7 000 years i cannot
make that logical jump
you know i i just couldn't so it needed
more and i totally agree
needed more
uh backstory right there um well i'm
almost wrapping up here guys so
something i don't always do but maybe i
should start doing if you have any
questions you want to ask a question in
the chat you guys are a little behind
um
so i see john carl demaid uh you know
you guys know i'm on king and a sting uh
i said dalia crying was touching not
enough men can express their gratitude
for male friendship i totally agree with
you 100 man i you know
i don't care me you know if you guys
watch me and know me i don't mind
showing my emotions i don't mind i'll
cry on a hat i cried about glassman
um you know it just it is what it is so
i i feel like there's nothing wrong with
expressing your emotions and that that's
such a old
it's such an old feeling of being like
man have to be a man you know all this
like whatever that means whoever defined
that
i reject it i reject that premise that
being a man means you don't show any
emotions and you have to be able to lift
uh crates
and whatever that is no i i think being
strong is being able to
show your emotions and then handle it
how you handle your emotions after is
the thing uh not everything should be
shared in public obviously but you know
being emotional and sensitive is not
you're not weak
you know you're not weak it's how you
embrace them and deal with them that's
what shows you
um
somebody said can you do more woo-woos
you only get two more for you
uh
i don't know what's the next movie i'm
gonna look at
when i
uh you know what i review it's just
movies come out and i just do it or
sometimes i'll watch a movie on amazon
or some like movie that came out two or
three years ago and it just intrigues me
and then sometimes it's so crazy that i
like to do these like movie recaps i'm
actually looking for an animator
somebody gave me a good idea that i
should animate my movie reviews like
when i recap a whole movie if somebody
animated it that would be kind of cool
and i actually think that's actually a
cool idea
uh
but i don't even know if it's even
possible to do that because would that
be copyright infringement because i'm
talking about a movie that's already
been made and now we're i don't know you
guys would have to tell me it is what it
is i appreciate your support as always
guys make sure you subscribe
you know share hit the notifications so
you get it
uh make sure you follow me on twitch
you know because because because what
i'm gonna start doing with my twitch is
i'm going to go on twitch and do
justtalk
be on twitch and then i'm going to make
that subscriber only chat
on twitch and then the people that can
watch the videos subscriber only video
watch and that'll be the videos i also
put up on patreon and my youtube members
and for my youtube
members so you can become a youtube
member you can become a patreon member
share follow subscribe and all that
great stuff and then i have to do real
world advice from a grown ass man i'll
probably do that next week i haven't
done it
i did watch severance guys severance was
great i guess i could do another full
recap of severance because it was
fantastic ending to severance but i'll
leave that for another time maybe i'll
do that next week too finish up with
severance so you have an opportunity to
go watch it so
uh you know i don't spoil it so make
sure if you're into what if you want to
watch severance now's the time you watch
it you have a week finish it it's only
10 episodes because i will i probably
will talk about it
i probably will talk about it next week
so we could um
um we could uh you know what i mean
we could recap that so
anyways guys
another live episode in the books you
know how i do it it's just right off the
cuff
no edits
just get it out
i appreciate all of you guys your
comments
super chats
support
you can even send me a tip in the in if
you want to you know you can support the
show in so many different ways i
appreciate it
and
that's it and i will see you
next week
[Music]
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]